hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast applying principles of
biosafety in laboratory animal
facilities
I'm Brenda Kelly Kim of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by the Andersons lab
bedding products as a sole manufacturer
of betel cobs the Andersons has provided
the research community with the most
trusted name in bedding since 1962 from
irradiated and qualified products
available in Auto cleavable and bulk
bags to sterility and heavy metal
testing the Andersons
provide a number of services to the
industry for more information please
visit www.carmensognonvi.com/newsletter
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your question through
the Q&A button lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Jim Swearengen dr. Swearengen is the
comparative medicine veterinarian for
the national bio defense analysis and
countermeasures center and a former
senior director of the Association for
assessment and accreditation of
laboratory animal care internet dr.
Swearengen received his veterinary
medical degree from the University of
missouri-columbia and completed a
four-year residency in laboratory animal
medicine at Walter Reed Army Institute
for Research in Washington DC I will now
turn it over
dr. Swearengen Thank You Brenda for that
introduction and I'd like to thank
everyone for attending today but I'd
like to thank the organizers of the bio
conference live series and staff who've
done their very best to ensure that I'm
appropriately trained and minimize the
opportunities for my messing this up so
I done a wonderful job and I want to
thank them for all their assistance I
have a very privileged - I feel very
privileged to be here today and talk to
you all about applying principles of
biosafety and laboratory animal
facilities and as you heard you know I
got about 25 years of experience in
working and infectious disease research
and one of the things that I found
infectious disease research is you look
at the biosafety guidelines a lot and
you become very familiar with the
principles that that are espoused in not
only the biosafety and biomedical
laboratories mycological laboratories
not only that kind of documentation but
in in the textbooks and things - and so
I thought as I was putting this
presentation together is it you know
there's a lot of those principles
biosafety that apply in all aspects of
laboratory animal facility facilities
whether involved with bio hazards or not
and while this presentation will talk a
little bit about the bio containment and
those types of hazards it's really going
to focus on how those principles can be
applied to laboratory animal facilities
in general and I think there's a lot of
things we can we can learn from those
approaches in the biosafety industry so
with that just to give you an overview
of the of the presentation
one of the principles that I've learned
to appreciate significantly is hazard
identification and in my early days in
this field you know I not sure we did a
real good job with this and I think
we're coming around and starting to do a
much better job but I think that's one
of those principles we could apply in
all animal facilities secondly we'll
talk about approaches to risk assessment
and while many people think about one
particular application of risk
assessment I'm going to try to talk to
you about multiple approaches and why
risk assessment can be applied to animal
facilities we'll also talk a little bit
about some laboratory practices and
techniques and some things that I've
seen and and have used over the years
just to share some of those things that
I think are have made significant
differences in both safety and biosafety
and laboratory animal facilities we'll
talk a little bit about safety equipment
and some of the issues with those and
then at the end we'll just kind of do a
quick review of the principle of
filadyne and construction and it applies
to a BSL - and a BSL three facilities
just to kind of give an overview of what
some of the requirements are out there
and some of the standards and guidelines
so with that let's go ahead and get
started
and we'll talk about first some of the
keys to effectively identifying hazards
that I think have been useful not only
in my career but I've seen others
implement them as well probably the
biggest thing upfront is making sure
that who's ever conducting the hazard
identification really has the experience
and qualifications to pick up and
identify the the dangers in the hazards
that are there a lot of times an animal
facility that falls to the veterinarian
and as a veterinarian I'm very aware of
many of the hazards associated with
using animals but I'm not an expert in
some of the other types of hazards that
others may be able to pick up with
different types of training and in
experiences one of the other ways to
help identify hazards is making sure
they're highlighted specifically and
animal use protocols and that safety
issues are reviewed by the appropriate
individuals that can as I said you know
adequately and we can be able to
effectively identify those issues
probably one of the most effective ways
in my opinion that I think helps with
hazard identification is having
regularly scheduled walkthrough reviews
of the animal facilities by
environmental health and safety
professionals as I said veterinarians
and veterinary staff may be very
familiar with certain hazards but may
not be able to pick up some of those
things that are not quite so familiar to
us so the review of institutional job
safety data is another area that a lot
of people may forget about when it comes
to the animal facility they may think
about that for things like their
physical plant workers or something like
that but not so much for the animal
facility and so you know looking through
OSHA logs or if you use near miss
reports that kind of data can be very
useful and looking for trends or looking
for things that may be easy fixes or or
trends that may need to be addressed in
a more in-depth manner so I think all
those things are really important when
you're looking to be able to effectively
identify hazards when you do the
walkthrough review that I talked about
earlier I think that as it's not just
highlighted in in the biosafety
literature but there's also a document
called Occupational Health and Safety
and the care and use of research animals
published by the National Research
Council which can be a great resource
and it talks about this particular issue
as well to involve your environmental
health and safety professionals in it
hazard identification control and that
it can enhance the involvement you know
can be enhanced by the involvement if
they don't care in research personnel
conducting reviews when working
researchers in progress is obviously
important it's much different walking
through a facility that's maybe shut
down for the afternoon versus in the
morning when things are at full peak so
determining when to go in and do your
evaluations can be important as well and
I think it's really important in this
aspect of Hazard identification to talk
to the people that are doing the work
every day and to get their opinions I
know some places that have taken this to
the level of including an evaluation
goal to recommend at least one Safety
Improvement during the year and and and
it may and I think I think that may be a
good idea or at least have some sort of
safety goal to get them thinking about
ways they can prove something and yeah
you know it could be as something as
small as you know how to better remove
your PPE when you're leaving an animal
area or maybe how to more safely mix
sanitizing Kempe chemicals and I think
just having them continue to think about
that get their opinions involved them is
is important because they're the ones
who really are going to know where those
hidden hazards lie that may not be
readily apparent during a routine
walkthrough so let's talk a little bit
about experimental hazards
there's a couple there's different types
of hazards obviously I kind of like to
break them down just for my own
edification into experimental and
non-experimental hazards kind of helps
me just be able to look in a different
way Adam rather than trying to look at
everything together and when you're
talking about experimental hazards
you're really looking at things like
chemical agents we talked about
things that may be used in everyday
cleaning and chemicals and in the
everyday husbandry that may occur but
there's also things associated with with
studies themselves the experiment that's
going on such as if you're using
volatile anesthetics
as part of the study or carcinogens or
toxins obviously biological agents you
know they're there's a lot of aspects
you have to look at the agent as and
conclude not only variant pathogenicity
and how its transmitted but also how its
transmitted in the animals a lot of
times it's transmitted differently in
animals than it is in people and I think
that's important to be able to look at
it to that level things like ionizing
radiation radiation if you're using
x-ray machines as part of a study
radioactive compounds and also looking
at the zone attic potential the species
being used in the study and you can see
on the slide a list of several different
concerns that might come up whether
you're using sheep or not in primates
especially if you start looking at
wild-caught rodents you might want to
consider you know have they been tested
for hantavirus or if not what
protections are you using prairie dogs
can obviously carry plague so you know
there's a lot of things that you can
look at from from a Reese from a hazard
standpoint with with using animals both
exceeded with the experiment or and all
these could be as part of an experiment
or some of them could be non
experimental hazards as well just as
natural diseases of animals that you
want to consider kind of when I look at
non experiment on the hazards I kind of
think about the more mechanical type
things bites scratches kicks which we
all know can happen with the can occur
when working with animals
the use of shark sharps or cleaning
chemicals pressurized containers you
know pressurized gas cylinders I'll talk
a little bit about that a little later
on and give you an example of way we try
to reduce that risk using pressurized
gas cylinders if you're using fish or in
your cage wash area where you have areas
with high moisture content lots of water
use that there's certainly risks with
electricity being because all those
things all those areas have outlets and
many times there's extension cords and
things like that that you want to make
sure we don't present an electrocution
rest either animals or people
ergonomic you know sometimes we forget
that the type of work that happens in an
animal facility can have significant
economic repercussions such as
repetitive motion of changing cages
cleaning cages handling animals lifting
many times there's significant lifting
requirements in an animal facility as
well of course machinery rack washers
probably one of the biggest hazards
significant hazards within an animal
facility being trapped inside a rack
washer you know looking at that as a
hazard is requires a close look and
there's a number of significant steps
you can take to minimize those risks as
well
noise hazards we work with in animal
facilities there's a lot of machinery
the rack washers themselves the animals
themselves things like that can present
noise hazards as well and then of course
we can't forget the old slip trip
hazards that we certainly want to be
aware of and be looking for in an animal
facility
now we kind of talked a little bit about
risk assessment let's move on to risk
assessment and there's this quote out of
the occupational health and safety care
and use of research animals that I
mentioned a little bit earlier gives a
nice quote where it says risk is a
measure of the likelihood of a
consequence where it's hazard the
inherent danger in a material system so
we kind of talked a little bit about the
hazard portion so let's kind of move on
and talk about the risk assessment
aspect and how risk assessment in
general can be applied to to an animal
facility so let's talk about the next
step in in risk assessment this kind of
goes back to some of the same principles
you saw in hazard identification in that
you may have to make sure people are
knowledgeable of the risk and procedures
in managing and before they can do an
appropriate risk assessment and we'll
talk a little bit about that as we
continue to move wrong determining the
importance of a hazard is it's very
important as well
there's a lot of considerations when
you're doing that as you can see there's
a number of them there that all can have
an impact on the importance of the
hazard not all hazards are created equal
and then once you you know have those
hazards the part of the risk assessment
process toward as you've assessed the
risk and determine the level of risk is
to develop mitigation strategies and not
only implement them but make sure your
workforce is trained I would like to
just interject a comment here when we're
talking about effective risk assessment
and determining importance of a hazard
is there's another R I like to throw in
with risk assess and that's risk
assessment that's cause reason I think
it's important to use reason and risk
assessment together just an example that
I had heard about recently was in
a certain place there are certain
activities that required using two pairs
of gloves and you know the old adage if
two is good more is better
came back with well then you know if we
need to then we might need three that
would be even better as it was
implemented they realized there was
significant issues with loss of
dexterity and increased the risk of
accidents from other reasons dropping
things not being able to adequately
manipulate things to the level that they
needed to so again I think it's really
important as we're talking about this
that all of these aspects of risk
assessment have to be considered
together along with reasonableness so
when we're talking about risk assessment
again you know things that I like to do
to kind of I guess I'm a splitter rather
than a lumper is to look at I look at
risk from both a job category
perspective and an individual risk
perspective and as you can see from the
cartoon there that you know these are
good examples of high consequence but
low probability events and again this
comes back to that reasonableness that I
talked about earlier is you really have
to look at the risk as a whole at the
hazard as a whole and do a really
comprehensive risk assessment to to come
up with a reasonable solution so let's
look first at job category risk
assessment as you can see here in a in
animal facility you may have a wide
variety of quote unquote job categories
or activities and while each of these
categories present may be different
physical risks and they certainly
present different levels of risk some of
the hazards we talked about earlier
working in near
washers may apply to animal caregivers
and cage wass attendants but may
certainly may not apply to investigators
or sitting scientists or summer students
I cook members institutional Animal Care
and Use Committee members who may be
evaluating animal facilities once every
six months aren't going to have the same
level and intensity of exposure as an
animal technician or maybe an animal
caregiver so again while we have
different job categories we have to
understand that they all present
different levels of risk as well so if
you look at individual risk assessment
rather than job category risk assessment
this is where we really get into the
more medical aspects of the risk
assessment process and nearly all the
the guidance you see out on this
perspective talks about the need to
include the guide for the care and use
of laboratory animals talks about the
need for having qualified health
professionals being involved with the
occupational health and safety program
and it's really important that they have
the knowledge of the risks associated
with the animal care news program as
well and that may take a little bit of
education but it's very important that
that's done the medical evaluation
really should occur at or near the time
of employment but certainly the idea is
that it occurs prior to animal exposure
and then of course you always have to
take into account the confidentiality
regulations when you're developing this
type of program a medical evaluation
program as part of the individual risk
assessment I'm going to throw a couple
other types of risk assessments out and
at you that I think I found is valuable
in my career for a number of reasons but
you know one of the things that a lot of
us may struggle with especially in
working in the affect
zees arena is immunizations and just
like anything else vaccinations should
be you know if you look at the guidance
that's out there talks about pre
exposure immunization should be offered
to personnel with risk of infection or
exposure you know a good example of that
is tetanus which is highly recommended
for animal care personnel and
vaccination against rabies for people
working with animals capable of
transmitting the virus so those are kind
of person you know kind of
straightforward recommendations that
you'll see out there where it gets a
little bit dicey here and where I think
the risk assessment really becomes more
really a more serious issue is for those
who or may need back who may be
considering vaccination with
experimental vaccines or infectious IND
vaccine sometimes they're they're called
and and these types of vaccines if
you're looking at those I think it's
really important that part of the risk
assessment process not only be thorough
but also ways both the benefit of the
vaccination versus potential harm some
of these IND vaccines can have potential
significant side effects and I think
it's really important that those B be
evaluated appropriately from both sides
specific recommendations can be found in
the biosafety microbiological and
biomedical laboratories or the PMD ELLs
I mentioned earlier with regard to some
of these
IND vaccines and and can be very useful
CDC website also has a lot of really
good information on these types of
vaccines as well so all that really
needs to be taken into consideration and
some places I know have actual
committees that look at this and make
determinations based on on a risk
assessment process the other type of
risk assessment that I am real avid
supporter of is a day at what I like to
call a daily risk assessment and this
kind of came about with as you know as
you people who work with animals and
work with hazards realize that the
animals themselves can present new
hazards that can change on a daily basis
and you know I'll I think some of the
reasons that doing a daily risk
assessment and how it might be done can
be and how it can be done we'll talk
about here but I think it can be very
useful probably the first step in in
doing this is just meeting prior to
going into into animal areas or in if
you're using hazard stage and
entertainment areas and to really just
to sit down take a few minutes to
discuss the day's activities and what
everybody's roles are but also to
identify any new hazards and one of the
things we found is a infectious disease
research you know animals dispositions
can change from not only day to day but
actually you know from hour to hour but
you know many times on a daily basis
you'll start to see changes animals
they're not feeling well can become
guarded and any and can present and
become aggressive and present new
hazards from that perspective so when
people see changes if you're not
relaying that information communicating
well that can present an unknown hazard
so sitting down on a daily basis going
through talking about the
the new has what you're going to be
doing any new hazards that are being
introduced or changeable solute
disposition can help you develop a
mitigation plan right there that morning
for any identified hazards and I think
it's a very useful activity that can pay
dividends and it's a cultural activity
because it's it's not a set time on your
Outlook calendar it's just something
everybody has to be used to doing to be
able to sit down and do it just without
thought that this is going to happen so
you really have to embed it into the
culture to make it useful but in my in
my experience I found it to be very
useful now we're going to kind of move
on back into the medical realm again
looking at medical evaluations as part
of the program medical surveillance
program I'm not going to talk a lot
about these particular issues or these
different types of medical evaluations
if anybody's really interested you can
go to the referencing at the bottom of
the slide there that I've mentioned two
or three times already but just briefly
to review you and we talked about the
importance of pre placement medical
evaluations as part of the personal risk
assessment that needs to be considered
periodic again depends on the risks that
are there some places may do annual some
may do every two years and again it
really needs to do it be risk-based
depending on the needs of the program
episodic is typically when there's a
potential exposure exposure and that's
kind of a your typical follow-up to that
kind of episode and then exit
evaluations are really uncommon there's
a lot of issues associated with that and
while there are some places where that
occurs it's it's not a it's not a common
activity in most programs so let's look
at change kind of change gears here a
little bit we've talked about the hazard
identification and risk assess risk
assessment aspects of
applying those principles to an animal
program and now I'd like to talk a
little bit applying the principle of
laboratory practices techniques to an
animal program as well so one of the
things that you see in the bmbl book
that you see there on the slide
they talk about evaluating a variety of
things to include technical proficiency
and I think it's important because
sometimes these terms go by us and we
thank all technical proficiency okay
we've got to make sure people are
trained and I think it you need to read
a little bit more into it than than just
training technical proficiency is really
more than just training it's it implies
that they have them they demonstrate the
ability to complete a task effectively
and safely on a continuous basis some
may call it competency different here
different names but in the industry but
I think we have to understand when we're
talking technical proficiency that's the
the level that we're talking about here
and these types of things as proficiency
or competency includes you know not
handling each species of animal as we
all know as I've said many times or said
at least a couple times all animals
aren't created equal and so you know
it's important that they have the
appropriate proficiency for each species
any experimental procedures that may be
being performed but also in this arena
it's not just with the animal sometimes
those samples are then also taken and
processed if they're collecting samples
and so they also have to have the
ability to handle those samples with
good microbiological practices sterile
technique and in some cases and you know
how to use equipment that may not be a
normal part of a non containment animal
facility such as you know biological
safety cabinets so you know that
technical proficiency can extend out
beyond just the animal handling
procedures also need to evaluate when
you're looking at
people and evaluating them evaluate
their experience and as well as the type
of traits they have and this one's a
little bit more subjective but I would
say no less important is looking at
people you know how and how attentive
they are when they're beginning
instruction how what level of caution
they tend to to apply their ability to
respond to emergencies do you evaluate
them regularly on that sometimes it's a
good idea just to pop in and and ask
someone okay this just happened what are
you going to do and and test them on
their their ability to respond to
emergencies because issues that are
things that aren't used frequently need
a little bit more reminding and maybe
refresher training than others
accountability that's that's really a
big one as well do you see people being
accountable for their actions if they
make a mistake are they do they own up
it to it or is their first response to
point a finger and blame someone else
you know while these are again as I said
subjective they're important traits that
that people that you need to evaluate in
people as well as concern for other
safety do they think of others first are
they making sure and being proactive
about helping others be safe as well and
correcting others when something may not
be done quite right and those are all
traits that we hope we can see in all
our staff and and everyone working in
animal facilities or laboratories and I
think it's it's good that you know if
you look at all these things
those should also be part of the
individual risk assessment process as
well so kind of lump those back into
some of the previous things we were
talking about as far as the risk
assessment process I think there are all
important traits that that need
evaluation so let's look a little bit
about informed workers you know we it's
as I mentioned you should be able to go
in and ask them about the hazards of
their job and should be able to explain
and how how they mitigate those hazards
you need to check to make sure they're
proficient implementing those safeguards
and consistency is probably one of the
biggest issues that I think everyone
struggles with and that just comes
through constant reminder constant
monitoring and an evaluation of some of
those things that we talked about just a
little bit before the the ability to you
billing for follow SOPs and policies is
probably one of the if we can attain
that we've made a big steps towards
working safely in animal facilities and
it's but probably one of the hardest
things to do as well so I'm going to
just share with you a few thoughts that
I had that I thought were kind of good
examples of how you can implement safe
laboratory practices and techniques that
can make a bit small things that I think
can make a big difference one of the
things that I really try to harp on is
placement of sharps containers a lot of
times people start procedures have a
needle a syringe and needle in their
hand and then start looking around for a
sharps container and I'm sure many of
you have probably seen that as well one
of the things I really emphasize in
training and proficiency evaluations are
where that sharps container is placed
you know is it near the worksite the
other thing it nearby its also making a
an assessment of you know is it going is
the placement nearby also avoiding
crossing of arms and hands or if there's
people sharing one are you avoiding the
the chance that somebody's going to
reach over somebody else's arm so
placement can be more than just nearby
and I think that's really important
one of the other things that I think I
feel and I know there is probably
different opinions on this but I feel
the needle safety systems have made a
big difference there's a whole variety
of needle safety systems if you look at
the center of the slide towards the top
you can see see if I can make this work
here you can see this here which is the
retractable so as soon as the plunger is
fully depressed the needle retracts
stuff inside the needle they have the
covering type here where you manually
push a shield over the top of the needle
when you're when you're done there and
there's probably a dozen different types
of systems out there but I think you
just need to look and see which ones
might be might be a good addition to
your program and again they're they're
not for all circumstances at all times
but at least in my experience I think
they've made a significant difference
one of the other things with regards to
implementing safe laboratory practices
is one of the things I've seen in some
places being introduced and a little bit
more and more which I'm glad of it's
positive reinforcement behavioral
training and I've got a couple pictures
here through our walk with you but in in
this picture right here you can see a
sheep and a headstand ssin and in this
particular case what you can't see is up
here is this gentleman right here is
holding a marshmallow up for this sheep
who has voluntarily put their head in
the gate and is having a marshmallow a
little ml cream was provided here for
some topical anesthesia and it's having
blood drawn without any notice that it's
even being done this is you know this
not only improves science the animals
are less stressed safety they're not
struggling and trying to fight the
restraint system but also animal welfare
improves
that bond that proves the relationship
between the people and the animals
themselves and I think overall improved
safety as well the pictures on the right
you can see here the first one in this
case they took a laser pointer and this
was from a poster that I came across
recently and they've used a pointer to
trained non-human primates to text to
test their water likes it and not only
test it but to also take a drink and and
again this is something that a lot of
places have and I remember back in the
day you know put your arm in here and
test the water looks at form that's
certainly not a good idea
others use stainless steel poles to go
in and touch the licks it again that
many times can stress out the animal
they animal can grab the pole so again
this particular thing in about ten
minutes a day for about two weeks you
can teach an animal to test their own
water licks it and so these are just a
couple examples of how you can use
different different things that you may
not think be are related to laboratory
safety but are very uses you can apply
them in a way that improves not only an
whelk they're fair but worker safety as
well I talked a little bit about
compressed air compressed gas cylinders
before and as anybody who knows who's
worked with compressed oxygen or
compressed co2 you know if these things
fall and you know damaged the top they
can go through brick they can go through
concrete walls they can here's an
example right here one that went through
a wall that got away and and especially
if you're working in a hazardous
environment moving these types of things
in and out of a facility into a into a
hazardous area can cause a little bit of
trepidation and so
something to consider is using oxygen
concentrators which is right here and I
think these there you see a little point
to it right there you can see a little a
tank there but that's really just for
backup that unless you have a power
outage that e tank never has to be
changed out and you know where someone
may have to change out e tanks on a
weekly basis you may go years without
ever have to change this e tank and so
you don't have to move compressed gas
cylinders in and out of your surgery
area or in and out of your animal
facility or in and out of containment
areas and these compressed gas are these
oxygen concentrators I've used them they
work great and just I think a real
improvement in safety without having to
deal with constantly moving compressed
gas cylinders and not a facility that is
if you don't have you know inline o to
or C you know to your to your facilities
this can be a very helpful safety
equipment some examples I just want to
talk what about the concept of primary
barriers and most the guidance that you
look at out there talks about the use of
primary barriers based on it should be
used based on risk assessment and as you
can see down at the bottom there's
several different types of primary
containment devices as well as up
towards the top here and here
you know biosafety cabinet centrifuge
cups are examples of on a smaller scale
of primary barriers a primary
containment for animals you can see down
here several at least right here you can
see several different types we've got
rodent rabbit and onion primary primary
containment caging downdraft tables over
here they also make portable downdraft
tables now
and it's important to remember that
these primary barriers can include not
just the equipment but also techniques
that guard against a release of
hazardous or biological materials in
general and they provide that extra
barrier between the worker and the
environment engineering controls are you
know provide engineering controls like
are provided by the primary containment
devices that that I mentioned here
really should be considered first before
relying solely on PPE for protecting
personnel and while that's felt
recommended a number of places the guide
for the care and use of laboratory
animals also makes a specific point of
talking about the use of primary
barriers first versus trying to use PP
is your it's your first line of defense
a good example that is allergens in
animal facilities rather than putting
somebody in a n95 would a betting dump
station that pulls the dust and
allergens away from the person be more
preferable so just some examples of
they're an example of where primary
containment or primary barriers and
engineering control should be used first
some of the most common biosafety
cabinet mistakes that you'll see out
there and again any of you use these are
well aware of those probably the biggest
mistake is putting them in the wrong
location where there's room air currents
that come from doors being opened
enclosed during the day as people walk
by traffic all those air currents can
disrupt the cabinet you know raising
this ash to high disabling the alarm so
you can raise this ash to high crowding
work surfaces in blot which can also
block the directional air form just for
technique not you know decontaminating
hands things like that before they come
out so again these are probably some of
the more common things that we can look
at
when we're evaluating how people work to
ensure that these are used as they're
designed to be used safety equipment we
talked about PPE kind of being that last
line of defense there's several
different types of PPE listed there I
did want to mention just a couple things
that I've come across in my career this
picture on the left right here is a new
it's the first time I've seen this it's
a rabbit cage with built in a restraint
mechanism and I don't know if you can
see in the slide there's kind of a
hashed stainless steel panel on the back
and it's designed a lot like a nonhuman
primate cage where you can pull the
rabbit to the front of the cage if you
need to access them for maybe to
chemically restrain them or something
like that without actually having to
pull the animal out and hold it to to to
make the injection so I think that's a
nice step forward in those cases where
you might need something like that wear
safety equipment can be a value-added
the picture on the right here these
Kevlar gauntlets here you know in a
previous position we were starting to
have issues with rabbits who would
scratch through the lab coats or the
scrubs and we noticed that the biggest
majority of those occurred on on the
back of the hands and the forearms and
using these Kevlar gauntlets is that the
other place really made a big difference
in reducing injuries from from as we all
know that rabbits have very powerful
back legs just one little word of of
caution with the Kevlar gauntlets is if
you use them in containment and use
bleach as your primary for priming your
primary disinfecting deep for
decontamination these things melt like
butter
when bleach get on them it's just a
reaction that breaks down the material
and they'll fall apart on you pretty
quickly so just a little thought there
if you ever decide to use them to that
you know that ahead of time before you
buy them
secondary barriers or facility design
and construction as we all know that if
you look at the bmbl again talks about
how it can tree how facility design
really does contribute to not only
worker protection but also to protect
persons outside the lab laboratory or
animal area also the community and the
level of barriers depends a lot on the
risk of transmission and there's some an
examples included down below there that
talk about you know you have to decide
based on your risk do you need
specialized ventilation systems air
treatment systems controlled access and
physical separation and I have I have
several slides that that kind of go
through really some of the facility
design considerations for a BSL and a
BSL to and and not so much focused on
just the conventional animal facility
and I'd like to I know we're kind of
approaching about 10 10 12 minutes out
I'll try to go through these fairly
quickly because I'd like to have make
sure we have ten you know five or ten
minutes at the end or maybe more to
answer any questions that may be coming
along so I'll really just kind of hit
the highlighted area in these slides to
make sure we have a little bit of time
for questions the area the the on the
slides the words that you see that are
in in more of a red maroon color are
things that when I first went through
the fifth edition of the bmbl when it
came out were a little bit different or
maybe there was an emphasis on it and so
those things will kind of focus
that likes a a new emphasis or a little
different from the fourth edition of the
bean bill and while the fifth editions
been out a while you know sometimes some
of us been doing this a while we forget
that as new editions come out we tend to
think about the old version rather than
new one so y know it's been out a little
while we'll just go through and
highlight those very quickly so if you
look at a BSL to facilities in addition
to your typical restricted access that
the bmbl talks about talks about having
secured and locked external doors your
animal room door issues pretty much stay
the same animal room ventilation they
did focus a little bit more on making
sure it emphasized inward airflow and
negative pressure to adjoining hallways
and they also talked about having an
autoclave in the animal facility as the
wedding they particularly use so for
those of you looking at
maybe renovating or designing animal
facilities the bmbl provides a lot of
guidance with regards to what they're
expecting what its expectations are
regarding animal facilities the kind of
the key point one of the changes here in
this particular slide and you can read
that as I'm talking here but it one of
the changes talks about recommending
having a mechanical washer for cages in
maybe not specifically inside BSL to a
BSL 2 but having it available as as a
recommendation for cleaning cages these
are all pretty straightforward and and I
like to call means this particular slide
thing terms like sealed penetration slip
resistant floors I kind of like to call
those the performance standard criteria
which doesn't tell you how to seal the
penetrations and tell you what floor
type you used to be slip resistant but
just states that that's what that's the
the engineer or the poor
it's criteria that needs to be attained
when you're building these facilities or
renovating them these are all pretty
straightforward too and it kind of just
realizes you know that they talk about
having an autoclave in the facility for
decontamination and so forth so all
pretty standard things
it's talks about methods of
decontamination and also that those
procedures should be validated at
propria tentacles it doesn't tell you
what that interval should be but implies
that it should be on a regular basis and
you have as you can see down the bottom
lots of different mechanisms everything
you know simple to more complex you know
biological indicators buoy get-backs
things like that so there's a lot of
different ways you can evaluate those
your your autoclaves but does need to be
done on a regular basis for a BSL -
under ventilation pretty much
straightforward is what we talked about
in word negative pressure no
recirculation and so forth so pretty
straightforward stuff there when you
start moving into a BSL three you you
have to take a BSL one and add a BSL two
and then at a BSL three it's they build
upon each other and that's made pretty
clear in the in the bmbl that that's how
these requirements work so if you look
at facilities prettiest it looks a lot
like a BSL - talks a little bit more
about security as far as it being
separated from other areas and access
restrictions and things like that so it
starts to get a little more detailed on
some of these things and it also talks
about
adding additional protections you know
whether your showers or HEPA filtration
effluent decontamination and again these
it's very clear in indicating that all
these additional environmental
protections should be determined by risk
assessment of the particular site and of
course always applicable federal state
or local regulations the operation the
facility has to be documented and tested
to verify it works like it's supposed to
work andrey verified annually so that's
something that in the three that you
don't see in the floor and here's some
of the highlights just to kind of
summarize a little bit some of those
things we've talked about it also starts
talking now about double-door entry that
the autoclave is convenient to animal
rooms not just in the facility and so
again things start to become a little
more a little more discreet so
hands-free or automatic washing sinks
and I think this is important too
because while I think a lot of us
struggle with this having a sinks in the
enhancing hand washing sinks in the
anteroom how to use them you know it
does say that you know hand washing
procedures should preclude contamination
of personnel or breach and room
containment barriers so you know the
location is important of the sinks as
well they should be out by the doors not
in the back of the room and those
procedures for using that same need to
be well thought out because the last
thing you want to do is try to be doing
the right thing and then making things
worse we've already talked about
biosafety cabinets a little bit so I
won't get on with those and then a
little bit more on ventilation that kind
of repeats a little bit what we talked
about earlier
and with a bsl-3 they talk about
mechanical washer required versus
recommended and some other things that
we kind of already touched on and just
so we have some room for questions I'm
going to skip this last slide it's
pretty pretty straightforward and again
a lot of this you can take right out of
the bmbl so with that I'd like to open
it up for questions and and so we can
give a little bit of time for you all to
ask anything you'd like to ask
so Brenda I'm going to pass it or should
I pass it over to you
wait a second I'm sorry I had some
questions here here's a question it says
do you consider a risk factor the number
of hours that people work in rodent
animal facilities during the day and I
enter that would be yes I think one of
the things that that is probably under
law or under evaluated is fatigue and I
think again that's becoming more more
prominent in the risk assessment arena
I think fatigue has to be taken into
consideration how many hours a day how
many times they do a repeated motion as
especially in in containment or in non
containment in just regular animal
facilities I think fatigue has to be a
very important part of that
consideration and especially in some
places overtime is used a lot and and
you know we kind of you can't gotta
watch that too because too much overtime
I know people like overtime but it can
also have adverse effects as well so I'm
gonna go to another question it says see
four chemical hazards well-known that
just about anything can become toxic
with high enough exposure how do you
create a list of hazardous chemicals to
be monitored at your facility do you
assess the level of hazard depending on
the quantity of exposure even for
mutagenic or territories agents I think
and and that's a great question because
that's I think something we all struggle
with you know one of the things that
I've seen done is is have a centralized
clearing house through the safety office
for hazardous chemicals and that any
hazardous chemical that or any chemical
basically that comes in the facility at
least in places I've seen
has to go through the Safety Office for
review for to look at things just like
you talked about you know mutagenic
teratogenic how it's going to be used
chemotherapeutic agents anti you know
even even drugs you know a lot of the
drugs used for cancer research so you
know I I think a good way to do that is
have a and that can be built into the
ordering system I know that can be a
little may be frustrating for people if
you don't have a good ordering system
but at least have a clearinghouse
through your health and safety office so
people who are familiar with those types
of hazards can evaluate them and
determine what those risks are as well
as being really good about making sure
you update your MSDS is in the area so
people are aware that have access to
those as well let's see here's a
question
who makes the rabbit cages with built-in
restraint mechanisms that you showed I
believe you know I again I'm not here to
to advertise for anybody but I believe
that's Allentown that makes those I'm
not sure they're on their website maybe
you want to call them and talk to them
about that and if they tell you I'm
wrong I'm sorry but I'm pretty sure that
too is who is making those it's least
the only place I know of right now
that's making them let's see let's see
here's a question here what's your
advice for dealing with EHS groups that
are overly risk-averse and boy that's a
good question it's a hard question again
it kind of comes back to that argument
of putting that second R and risk
assessment you know reason and while you
know I realize not everybody is
reasonable I think sometimes going out
and getting second opinions where
there's a real
where there's a real disconnect between
two parties it's always a good idea and
but other than that that can be a tough
one to deal with you have just a one
more minute left on my screen here and I
don't know if they're going to cut me
off right at one o'clock but I'll try to
ask tour one or two more questions so
let's see there's one here what types of
ergonomic concerns do you see is most
prevalent and how do you see addressing
these the I think you know a lot of this
is is facility and program dependent you
know I would say in in say may be large
or facilities that do large talk studies
or toxin safety studies where they do
you know several hundred animals a day
maybe doing IP injections or or pulling
it you know lifting pulling cages and
transferring cages and doing weights you
know your your things like tunnel carpel
and things like that can can be a big
issue I see I've seen a lot of that
probably one of the things I've seen
that that really is kind of caught my
eye recently is the whole lifting thing
as maybe as I get older I'm starting to
become more sensitive to I've become
more sensitive to that as my back gets a
little less stronger than it used to be
but I see and as our employees age I see
a lot of back injuries now not only from
just poor lifting technique but just not
maintaining good core strength things
that could be prevented through early
identification and year and maybe some
assistance with the ACT health and
safety program so anyway the
hopefully that those are the things I
think I've seen at least in my
experience let's see let me let me ask
to answer one more here let's see in my
facility we house mice seeded with human
tumors our biosafety offices insist we
soak the cages after bedding is dumped
prior to placing them in a pass-through
cage washer which reaches 180 degrees we
have proposed testing the contamination
levels on the clean side of the cage
watch to show they have been
decontaminated can you comment well I I
guess I that's a that's a great question
and and is pretty complex when in the
fact that there's numbers of areas of
risk assessment that need to be you know
that the number of areas that need to be
risk assessed it's it's not just one
particular thing if you're looking at
you know the the tumor cells the human
tumors and the animals you know is do
the tumor cells are they shed are they
in the cage you know what's the risk
there to anyone who comes in contact
with them what are you soaking him in
have you shown that that's effective if
that's a concern is that really make a
difference in you know the level of any
viable tumor cells it might be in the
cage and you know I guess the primary
concern here would be how do you address
those people if you've already shown if
you could show that the cage wash itself
we did eliminate any risk of human tumor
cells then the question is how you
protect them to people who are putting
the cages into the cage washer so that's
the part of the risk assessment that may
need to be a little more in
depth to look at what what the risk is
to those people and how you mitigate it
so sorry I don't have a real direct
answer for you but that's that's
probably the way I would approach it so
with that I think probably gone over as
much as I probably should want to thank
you all for the great questions I'm
sorry I couldn't get to them all but I
certainly appreciate your participation
and and the great questions that came in
so I'm gonna turn it back over to Brenda
and see if she would like to sign us off
thank you dr. Swearengen put that
wonderful presentation lots of food
questions unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience for
their participation in today's event and
I would also like to thank our sponsor
the Andersons lab that ain't products
for making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August 2015 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
Glen Cass will be available for replay
and we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues may have
missed today's live event thank you
again
bye